-Guys, it's hard to believe,
but it's been over a year
since we all got on Zoom.
And, yet, some people are still
getting the hang of it,
even people on TV.
So you know what that means.
It's time for another
installment of
"Greatest Moments
in Zoom History."
Enjoy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-What do you think is
most important,
most urgent right now?
-We have also heard reports that
grant funding has gone down de--
-I think I lost
Representative Clark.
-I understand that
Congresswoman Clark is back on.
-I hope this is
a more successful outing.
We are seeing --
-Representative Gerry Connolly
of Virginia,
who's the president of the
NATO Parliamentary Assembly,
for five minutes.
-[ Indiscernible robotic voice ]
-We're having a hard
time hearing you, Mr. Connolly.
You're coming in --
You're breaking up.
It's hard to understand you.
-[ Robotic voice ]
Can you hear me now?
-It is unbelievable
what we're seeing.
And -- And you're --
the quote by Bernie Sanders --
[ Echoing ]
-The gentleman is recognized
for five minutes.
-Today's gig economy
sprung out
from the last recession.
It offers a job to anyone
who wants one.
-Mr. Mfume, can you center your
mic or your computer
so we can see your face?
-I did not know, Madam Chair,
that you could not.
-I now call upon
the prime minister
of the Republic of India,
his excellency Narendra Modi.
-Your excellency,
President Biden.
[ Phone dialing ]
Colleagues.
My fellow citizens.
[ Phone dialing ]
-What made you want to do it?
-Well, my mom presented
the idea to me,
and she said that I could be
one of the first --
-I think we just lost Ty.
Ty, I think we have you back,
so I'll ask the question again.
What made you want to be
a part of this trial?
-And, John, in the early days
of this investigation,
what stands out to you the most?
-One-two, one-two, one-two,
one-two, one-two, one-two.
One, two, three, four, five --
-We can hear you, John.
-It's the most universal way
for all of us to stay active.
How you doing, there,
Matt Titus?
-So, let's see if
we can give Theresa a call.
-Hello?!
-Theresa!
-You're upside down, girl.
Will you flip
your phone upside down?
-We can't see you.
-This way?
-One more. One more click.
-One more.
One more. One more. One more.
-One more. One more.
Yeah!
-Yes!
-Okay, let's call Jackie.
-Okay. Here we go.
[ Video call ringing ]
-Hey -- Hi, Jackie.
How are you?
-Hi.
-I'm great. How are you?
-There you are -- Oh --
-Flip it the other way.
-Just one more flip.
Oh, one more.
One more.
-One more flip.
-Just a half a flip.
Freeze, freeze.
-I love them both.
I hope it's true.
That would be awesome.
-Oh!
-Okay, good. Alright.
-We were just
saying the same thing.
-Oh, no.
-Oh, my gosh!
-Kelsey, good morning.
Oh, can we not hear him?
-Can you hear him?
-I can't hear him.
-I can't hear him either.
-Uh-oh. Are you on mute?
-There we go.
-We had you for a second. Nope.
-[ Speaking native language ]
♪♪
[ Speaking native language ]
-Kits do it --
YouTube kits do it,
and the BBC are also now
embracing this.
Why -- I apologize for
my cat's tail.
Why are you...
-It's important to have
those protections in place
for everybody.
-Mnh-mnh. Uh --
-I think I -- Did I lose you?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"Um -- Uh -- "